Hi,
Dr. Peterson,
I'm a 17 year old girl and up tool gets
turned to rare for someone like me who
listened to,
well,
maybe it is,
but I don't think it is.
So you know,
there's this idea that the only people
who are listening to me or angry white
men,
he's a maker.
He might get in this whole idea
and brown women in the audience too.
As far as I'm concerned.
This is just so absurd as that.
I can't believe that this has
even become controversial,
is talking to people about,
you know,
taking responsibility for the
state of the world onto themselves,
the radical leftist identity politics.
City logs can only view this through the
lens of their radical leftist identity
politics.
And instead of noticing that
this isn't a political issue,
except that I don't like the radical
leftists and the restrictions on free
speech [inaudible] for me,
it's the politics junkie.
It's found founders,
the politicians started to do the things
that they don't get to do is staring
into philosophical realm or they stepped
into the theological rep and they
should stay the hell out of both
the individual.
You're,
you're no longer where you should.
You've transformed yourself into
a tire and not the good time,
not that there is a good conductor.
So now the consequences of God,
Carlos,
because our would be objected to that
vociferously and with a fair degree of
success,
the only responsible can be mounted is
the response that exists within that
domain of conceptualization
of identity politics.
And so since I'm objecting to that,
then I must be the reprehensible
editing slept well,
good luck with that story.
It's not going to work out
because that is what's going on.
So and so to the 17 year old girl,
it's like who knows how many 17 year old
girls are paying attention to what I'm
saying?
I need to,
I would say it's in the tens of thousands
and perhaps hundreds of thousands.
And so the mere fact that
that isn't the story,
that a small subsection of the ideological
he committed partner media is telling
you by no means all of them by any stretch
of the imagination doesn't mean it's
cannot be true.
So now when might be rare statistically
speaking for 17 year olds to be
listening to me,
but her plenty of them that are,
I get letters from them all the time.
More power to them as
far as I'm concerned.
It's a complicated message that lectures
are very sophisticated and difficult.
It's great if,
if you happen to find that your
interest is captured by them,
then there's something to that.
What advice would I give for teens?
Like you do what you think's right,
Kiddo.
[inaudible].